welcome to this video a tu at deal so
societ I don't get any five year ah
that's cool I don't get in any I wanted
I should win two Ponzi on easier and I
in and the cause of one week I'm getting
what do I get here 1e5 game I had 145
and appreciate them I played them before
in all of the games funny so what is
this night maybe knight to e to actually
493 maybe this is more testing than 90
for allowing a trade not sure sorry for
that sorry about that or for that hmm
this is one of the trickier sports the
English language those little connecting
words yeah I kind of expected that so
night everyone to send him back off
nigerianigeria actually making more
sense as like we need five I just take
on h7 okay it takes them which basically
gives me a great attacking position with
the f file open so to eat you are where
pawn to e4 looks wrong so I probably go
here maybe I should have done that just
quicker probably five so taking e 5 is
not on okay I'm just keeping this and
chap not a transformation that I had
expected
yeah nite chef form it's not very
convenient there how to get rid of very
strange that it can get away with all
that year Queen a five the Queen h5 and
and others but yeah I probably just
played a couple of bad moves them sharp
don't I don't know if this is any good
but I really didn't see a great
continuation
check
his night is not exactly having many
square so and his screen as well what is
he doing them go look at you one you
probably have please be 56 and then
maybe just g3 completely ignoring
everything here in this good pawned up
to d7 and then we should be six it just
looks like it should be good I think I'm
threatening now maybe not not yet but
probably just g3 jab but how do i
promote the porn in the first place
Knight takes d5 em and that this is
quite logical actually if equis knee
five would be probably winning as f4 and
c7 hangs okay he defended that but that
neglected control over a seven so I
might can maybe can just play going here
for Queenie seven is Bishop c5 probably
Bishop c5 is going to hoard okay come on
let's push this away and see where he's
going with it to hear okay so
yeah voice is just too simple just King
g2 at the time I'm allowing a check 1 C
2 don't tell me that this is now ok for
him probably it is a rook see to check I
just wanted to improve my position a
little bit maybe h4 I can go to h3 an
idea was to make his Queen look really
bad but so if i just take this time
warning go
I said there should be some way to
really win immediately let's say here
achik d44 26 or 27
just keeping a screen at bay so much as
as much as long as possible
Wow
and really expect a passive move my king
is still a bit in a bit if he there on
age three can maybe take from blackrock
cd7 yeah and just play a piece down and
trying to irritate me but just it's not
that easy he has got queens in one but I
broke the one so this is the shot Queen
f3 maybe working age to this must should
be okay wow just going for the time
that's nice please play king j checkmate
thank you whoo that was that was very
strange what a strange thing here my
chief form sure I really didn't i didn't
really evaluate that properly Bishop f4
is such a stronger keeping this and this
is this is surprisingly surprisingly
good the Queen on age six and then d 5
is also stronger yeah directly opening
up the position yeah I played that well
check so we've been starting around yet
it became a bit strange was really
surprised that you just allowed t6 I
mean it's very clear that I want to play
the six and it is just a threat I mean
why why rook c8 and ignore the whole
thing probably why because he spent two
seconds on the move okay like g6 and now
I'm winning her with the point of 27 but
it's still not easy one thing is this
move was just the routine move to keep
the pond and I saw 11 move later that
there's this 95 idea and in fact instead
of this 95 is winning immediately after
that he is similarly falling apart this
Hanks this hangs Queenie 8 over that
wins the whole whole board actually now
but this was again it was a quick move
but I've helped the time pressure and
there should be six just looked very
normal job and probably maybe here have
something better I don't know rook to e3
is really add I just a 10 groups it too
but he didn't play that I have to do
something like this I'm sorry like he
and queen before maybe this this is
Jesse this is this would have been good
yeah just a good technical way to do it
keeping control probably i can at the
right moment sacrificed exchange and
invade with the king but ok this allowed
books it to which it did not play went
down and here still i'm very ok again
and winning in fact yeah plus two okay
rook h1 quincy one now was stronger but
he played this person where that looked
wrong really look F wow ever was much
stronger yeah that hmm that's a move i
really could have seen just completely
cutting the Queen off it's a much
stronger of course
then Rugare too I wanted to avoid the
rook trade but I didn't understand that
their voice so much stronger and instead
of the he could have played Quincy one
and still it's not it's not easy for
what now I read tricky very tricky
position okay well thanks for watching